Ende nächster Woche beginnt der
Parteitag der Kommunistischen Partei
Chinas und es ist davon auszugehen dass
cheating Ping dort zum Diktator auf
Lebenszeit gekrönt wird das gab es noch
nie in der Geschichte dass ein Mensch
ein Mensch mit derart absoluter macht
ein wirtschaftlich so starkes Land
geführt hat und damit ist unser aller
Freiheit gefährdet und wir müssen sagen
leider leider hatte Deutschland ein
entscheidenden Anteil gehabt das ist so
weit gekommen ist als andere westliche
Politiker schon davor gewarnt haben war
es Angela Merkel die immer für einen
weichen Kurs gegenüber China eintrat aus
kurzfristigen Profitinteressen haben
volkswagen Daimler Benz Siemens und
viele andere ein Großteil ihrer
Produktion nach China Fahrrad und sucht
das kommunistische Regime dort stark
gemacht ich bin nun überhaupt nicht
dafür da jetzt ein symbolischen
symbolischen Sanktionen zu machen die
ich im Zweifel uns mehr Schaden als
cheating Ping aber was wir machen müssen
ist endlich wieder unsere eigene
industrielle Basis ausbauen selber
Computerchips produzieren selber
medizinische Geräte produzieren um so
unsere totale Abhängigkeit hier noch
viel größer ist als die Abhängigkeit von
Russland die totale Abhängigkeit von
China entscheiden zu reduzieren nicht
kein Handel mehr mit China zu betreiben
klar ist ein großes Land mit dem man
Handeltreiben muss aber unsere totale
Abhängigkeit entscheidend zu reduzieren
ist das klingt sehr dramatisch sind wir
im Endeffekt wenn ich sie richtig
verstehen noch abhängiger von China als
von Russland total also alles das haben
wir jetzt während der corona-krise
erlebt von den Masken bis zu dem
Beatmungsgeräten des kommt alles aus
China und wir sind noch umgekehrt
abhängig weil eben ich habe ein Beispiel
Volkswagen es gilt aber für die anderen
Autounternehmen genauso sich so klar die
haben gedacht ja klar großer Markt 1,4
Milliarden Menschen aber sich damit so
abhängig gemacht haben dass diese
Autounternehmen pleite wären wenn jetzt
zum Beispiel China Taiwan angreift und
wir dann uns entscheiden genau so China
zu boykottieren wie wir jetzt Russland
boykottieren während diese
Autounternehmen pleite und damit ein
Rückgrat der deutschen Industrie aber
kommen wir noch mal zum ukraine-konflikt
ist China da der lachende Dritte auf
jeden Fall weil also Chinas oder das
gemeinsame Ziel von cheating pinken
putin ist ja die Weltordnung zu
verändern und ja du wie sie sagen die
die westliche Vorherrschaft zu brechen
aber damit meinen Sie natürlich auch die
Vorstellungen von Freiheit Demokratie
und so weiter dass die nicht mehr als
nachahmenswertes Modell in der Welt
gelten sollen sondern ihre eigene Art
von
Regierungsführung und aber selbst wenn
selbst wenn Putin
anderen sollte was nicht im Sinne von
chiching Ping wäre aber selbst dann ich
meine das sind doch wir die die jetzt
frieren sind ja nicht die Chinesen die
haben ihre eigenen Probleme sicherlich
aber was das angeht wird durch diesen
Konflikt der Westen weiter entscheiden
geschwächt egal wie der Konflikt ausgeht
und Chichi King ist der lachende Dritte
da muss ich schon sagen ich teile diese
Einschätzung oder dass da eine starke
Achse auch heranwächst egal wie eng die
dann zusammenarbeiten aber das sind
Systeme die unser Bestes System
gegenüberstehen aber ich möchte auch
wissen daran erleben dass wir auch
selbstkritisch sein müssen im Westen
wenn ich finde das schon auch
unglaublich wenn wir jetzt wenn Sie die
ganzen Konflikte der ansprechen auch
Ukraine Kriege oder die man hat schon
einfach sehr unvorsichtig das gemacht
ich meine jetzt kann man schon sagen ja
gut böse Putin der böse schiedoute die
Chinese oder aber wenn ich mir überlege
was ist in den letzten Jahren passiert
ich war da auch meine Damen bei diesen
großen Demonstrationen 2014 bevor sie
diesen ja diese Explosion start-steich
gegeben hat mit Klitschko gemacht dann
auf den Straßen vollbartikaden das war
schon da die amerikanische Botschaft ist
darum gelaufen die haben mit
demonstriert ich meine es war schon ein
extremer Druck die die Nato ostenweitung
hat man hat einen russischen Bären auch
provoziert und natürlich ist das ein
Problem
da möchte ich einmal die Meinung der
anderen beiden Herren in der Runde ist
ja schon eine sehr steile These hier am
Tisch hier ist ja alles klar alles
erlaubt hier aber da muss ich natürlich
noch mal eine andere Meinung einholen
der Dorendorf wie sehen Sie das haben
wir den russischen Bären provoziert naja
also putin war hier hat im Reichstag mal
gesprochen ist ja schon ein paar Jahre
her hat man eigentlich gesagt dass man
nicht weitergeht man ist aber
weitergegangen man hat es versprochen
man hat versprochen man hätte man wollte
ihn einen auch eigentlich etwas stärker
in wirtschaftlichen Bereichen
integrieren das hat man eigentlich auch
nicht getan rechtfertigt nicht den
Angriff zu Ukraine das ist gar kein
keine Frage aber es ist nicht so einfach
wie man immer denkt ne sondern man hätte
wenn man ihm damals stärker ein hätte in
diese wirtschaftlichen Bereiche die man
ja auch eigentlich angesagt hatte und
wenn man nicht weiter gegangen
wäre es vielleicht genauso gewesen bei
der Krim hat man ja auch schon das war
ja sein erster Test sage ich jetzt mal
einfach so
da hätte man einfach ein bisschen
Schicksale reagieren wir reagieren die
westlichen Mächte wie gehen sie darauf
ein wie sie darauf ein oder lassen wir
es laufen das war ja alles diese also
richtig wir haben ja nicht viel gemacht
muss jemand runter gehen
zu seiner These und zwar Russland die
Lage ist jetzt wie sie ist das muss man
jetzt so sagen die Spekulation ob man
mit Russland hätte anders verhandeln
können die helfen uns gerade leider
nicht mehr weiter mit China ist die Lage
auch wie sie ist sind sie denn trotzdem
frohen Mutes wenn sie auf die
Handelsbeziehung zwischen Deutschland
und China blicken
also
das ist wir haben diese Abhängigkeit und
diese Abhängigkeit wirklich jetzt
zunehmend politisch aus weil was die
meisten Leute nicht begreifen ist wie
sich China verändert hat mit
dem Shopping damals und sein Nachfolgern
oder von ihm eingesetzten Leuten hat
China sich zur Welt geöffnet und war
sehr pragmatisch
mittlerweile unterschiedlichen ping geht
es wieder vor allem um Ideologie und
chiching Ping würde machen was seine
Vorgänger nicht gemacht hätten diese
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit die wir
haben ausnutzen wenn es um politische
Interessen geht da gibt es bereits viele
Beispiele dafür als Litauen eine
Vertretung von Taiwan aufgemacht hat
wurde das Land Litauen aus dem
Chinesischen zollverzeichnis gestrichen
das heißt es existiert nicht mehr das
betrifft jetzt nicht nur Litauen will
sondern betrifft alle Firmen aus der
ganzen Welt die Einzelteile haben in
ihren Produkten aus Litauen nicht mehr
liefern weil die in dem Zoll Verzeichnis
nicht mehr vorkommen als Bücher Botin
chinesischer Präsident im
Friedensnobelpreis bekommen hat hat sich
China entschieden
keinen Lachs mehr aus Norwegen zu kaufen
also Chichi Ping ist entschlossen seine
wirtschaftliche Macht für seine
politisch ideologischen Zwecke zu nutzen
und darum müssen wir uns mit diesem Mann
beschäftigen und wissen wer er ist Herr
geig ist damit wir jetzt nicht ganz so
düster aus der Sendung rausgehen weil
erst hatten wir Deutschland kennen sie
culture Atomkrieg ich kann heute gar
nicht mehr schlafen deswegen würde ich
die Herren einmal bitten dass jeder ich
fange bei ihnen mal an Herr dohrendorf
sie mal etwas Positives sagen warum sie
positiv in die Zukunft blicken dass wir
heute mal mit etwas Optimismus worin
Deutschland gut ist ins Ende gehen ich
glaube einfach die Situation die wir
jetzt haben die erdet uns ja auch auf
der anderen Seite wir waren ja auf einem
ganz hohen Niveau fallen jetzt gerade
ein bisschen tiefer und glaube ich
kommen zu der alten Stärke dass wir
einfach das hoffe ich und das glaube ich
auch dass wir die Ärmel hochkrämpfen
müssen da müssen wir natürlich einiges
so ändern ne Leistung sich wieder lohnen
arbeit muss sich lohnen wenn ich ein
Bürgergeld habe und ich brauche nichts
mehr machen und
die die Leute die so an der Schwelle
arbeiten wenn davon bestraft so geht sie
sagen Erdung jeder hat einen konsistent
was sagen sie Erdung ist schon weg ist
erdet uns die Krise was sagen sie ich
bin einfach deshalb optimistisch weil
ich nach wie vor der deutschen
Wirtschaft unglaubliche Fähigkeiten zu
schreiben ich habe immer wieder gehört
über Jahrzehnte hinweg Deutschland ist
am Abgrund und das geht bergab und immer
wieder hat sich Deutschland aufgrund
nicht der Politik wohlgemerkt mit der
Politiker das gar nichts zu tun sondern
aufgrund der unglaublichen Leistungen
der das Mittelstandes und der großen
Unternehmen Deutschland und darauf
vertraue ich nach wie vor und ich
vertraue auch darauf dass weil wir auch
über kulturelle Probleme gesprochen
haben das im Grunde der Wahnsinn mit dem
wir es heute zu tun haben der wooknis
heißt oder Politik korrectness dass er
implodiert ich denke nämlich das ist so
weit getrieben das ist so weit in die
Verrücktheit hineingetrieben dass das
auf Dauer nicht zu halten ist und dass
irgendwann eine junge Generation
nachwächst die wir das skeptisch ist und
die wieder auch Lust hat zu arbeiten und
nicht blöd zu arbeiten das muss ja ein
bisschen zur Eile anregen sie haben
jeder leider nur noch einen Satz was
gibt ihnen Hoffnung ich glaube der
Mensch der findungsreichtum ich glaube
ja die menschliche Vernunft an die
Menschen die es Schaffenskraft da die
menschen die Leidenschaft und wir werden
auch das hinkriegen die Politiker die
ihr jetzt nicht schaffen aber die
Menschen die normalen Bürger die werden
es schaffen meine optimistische these es
gibt einen Menschen der gefährlich
werden kann das ist selbst weil der
natürlich mit seiner Politik auch China
selbst schadet der chinesischen
Wirtschaft und so das Gegenteil
erreichen kann möglicherweise im
Endeffekt von dem was er möchte nämlich
China Schwächen und das wäre wiederum
also das kommunistische China Schwächen
das wäre wieder gut für